it was an announcement that changed the
political landscape in Washington
betrayal of his oath of office betrayal
of our national security House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi once reluctant to start
impeachment proceedings changed her mind
after a transcript of a call between
President Donald Trump and President
Vladimir's olenski of Ukraine was
released President Trump now stands
accused of abusing his power undermining
national security and inviting a foreign
power to interfere in u.s. elections
senior Democrats on the Intelligence
Committee say the Trump administration
won't be doing itself any favors
if it doesn't cooperate will the White
House fight us on this I have to imagine
they're gonna fight us tooth and nail
and yet even as they do the more that
they fight to try to prevent and
obstruct the lawful functions of
Congress the more they're gonna make a
case for impeachment on obstruction of
justice of Congress Republicans are now
rallying behind their embattled
president saying Donald Trump was
duty-bound to press the Ukrainians to
look into allegations about Joe Biden's
son Hunter and his dealings with the
Ukrainian energy company Trump's
personal lawyer Rudy Giuliani himself an
important player in the scandal is
likely to be called before House
Democrats if he decides that he wants me
to testify
of course I'll testify even though I
think Adam Schiff is an illegitimate
chairman misty has already prejudged the
case if we want fairness here we got to
put somebody in charge of that committee
who has an open mind impeachment
proceedings are now moving at a pace
that neither the Republican Party nor
President Trump can control at heart of
all this is a report from a so-called
whistleblower deemed credible by the
Acting Director of National Intelligence
it's thought he or she may appear behind
closed doors soon known as Luanne today
for both parties the stakes couldn't be
higher
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham one of
the president's closest allies says the
accusations a secondhand lies it's all
hearsay you can't get a parking ticket
conviction based on hearsay the
whistleblower didn't hear the phone call
right who told logistical or about the
phone call and everything else he says
don't try this
every American deserves to confront
their accuser so this is a sham what's
going on now is the single greatest scam
president Trump is now in the fight of
his political career and says the
proceedings are a hoax
Democrats say Trump's own words from his
phone call with the Ukrainian leader and
which he says do me a favor though are a
clear violation of the law and a
Gallacher al Jazeera Washington let's
get straight to Patty Cole hey news live
for us in Washington DC firstly patty it
appears at least on the surface the
support for impeachment is growing in
pace it is according to the polls and
keep in mind this has been just a matter
of days ahead and the entire universe of
Washington DC has changed since we saw
the Democrats come out and say that they
were going to pursue an impeachment
inquiry so we're seeing just the first
polls starting to come out and the
latest one comes from CBS network news
55% of Americans at that they asked a
proof of looking into this matter now
one of the bigger numbers I took out of
that is it's a very partisan divide
Democrats overwhelmingly want this to
happen Republicans not so much but the
president in polls has remained
incredibly popular with his core base of
Republicans but according to this poll
at least 23% of those Republicans say
this needs three looked into that could
spell problems for the president which
is perhaps it's a little bit behind this
tweet storm of his this evening and and
patty specifically talking about those
tweets he's talking about wanting to to
meet his accuser keep more can you tell
us about this and his other latest
tweets well let's start with money to
meet his accuser because every American
can do that but he's not every American
he's the President of the United States
this isn't a criminal trial this person
came forward under the whistleblower
statute which means that person is
protected so the president can say he
gets to face his accuser yeah that's not
how this works although it is believed
that they are really close to finalizing
the deal if they haven't already done it
with his attorneys to be able to speak
with him in private members of Congress
members of Congress like to leak so it
chances are
likely that this person's identity is
going to come out the other thing that
the president said is that Adam Schiff
lied on the house when he summarized
this conversation
you want some tried for trees and this
is something the president keeps talking
about this matter that's a really
serious thing treason can come with the
death penalty and he also said that the
could this was hearsay and that the
whistleblower didn't actually say what
the conversation was accurately but
here's the thing the president's White
House released basically a draft of what
was in the conversation it exactly
mirrors what the whistleblower said in
his statement so the president trying to
spin the president obviously very spun
up but he can't stop this it's moving
forward very important people are gonna
be deposed this week in Washington and
we're gonna know a lot more so if you
thought the last couple of days are fast
just give it a minute I'm sure he could
be watching it very closely indeed pat
eagle hain live in washington DC thank
you very much